et nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales donc
l'autre blanche maison
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors est-ce vraiment la semaine
du dénouement pour le break site
ce n'est pas si sûr puisque paraît que
jeune sun a dit il ya un peu moins d'une
heure comme vous venez de le mentionner
à ursula von der leyen qu' un accord
était désirable mais que les
négociations n'avançaient pas c'est
aussi le pignon de l'union européenne
simplement dans le passé johnson avait
dit avait présenté le 15 octobre comme
une sorte de date limite au-delà de
laquelle s'il n'y avait pas de
perspective d'accord
eh bien les britanniques cesserait de
négocier ce propos qui vient de tenir
par visioconférence à au co président du
conseil européen et à la présidente de
la commission semble indiquer que la
grande-bretagne bien sûr va continuer à
négocier
c'est en tout cas la position de l'union
européenne il n'y a pas de raison
d'arrêter la négociation elle peut se
poursuivre il y aura d'ailleurs un
nouveau conseil européen à la mi
novembre qui cette fois ci devra sans
doute statuer mais au bout du compte
dans une négociation tant que la limite
ultime n'est pas d'atteinte et bien on
peut toujours continuer à négocier et la
limite ultime c'est la fin de la période
de transition qui est prévue dans
l'accord de sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne qui est entrée en
vigueur le 31 janvier dernier
cette date limite c'est le 31 décembre
prochain donc à mon avis les
négociations vont continuer elles sont
difficiles parce que de chaque côté on
refuse la moindre concession
c'est dans le fond une tactique de
négociation les britanniques ne veulent
rien lâcher jusqu'à la fin johnson a été
élu sur l'idée de sortir le royaume uni
la de l'union européenne il l'a fait sur
le plan politique et lui reste à savoir
dans quelles conditions il le fera pour
l'union douanière et évidemment il faut
qu'ils le fassent au moindre coût
économique donc la négociation va
continuer alors la pêche c'est ce qui
met le royaume uni en position de force
et là ou là
france finalement le plus à perdre oui
enfin la france n'est pas toute seule
puisque nous sommes 5 si j'ose dire dans
le même bateau l'ado de pêche évidemment
puisque cinq pays de l'union européenne
pêche dans les eaux britanniques est
comme ça fait 45 ans que ça dure depuis
qu'il ya une politique commune de la
pêche et que la grande bretagne est
membre de l'union européenne
ce sont des droits qui sont devenus
quand un caractère quasiment historique
par conséquent il est très difficile de
les remettre en cause
alors bien sûr politiquement il n'est
pas question que la france fasse des
concessions sur ce sujet ces pêcheurs
doit pouvoir continuer à accéder aux
eaux britanniques mais les eaux les
quatre autres pays qui vont pêcher dans
les eaux britanniques sont dans le même
état d'esprit
de toute façon monsieur barnier et
négocie sur la base d'un mandat qui a
été arrêté par les conseils et qu'il
peut être modifiés qui peut être
assouplie qu'à l'unanimité et chaque
état membre a un droit de veto sur toute
modification de ce mandat de négociation
il est clair donc qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'accord au détriment des
pêcheurs français ou des pêcheurs
néerlandais belges danois ou espagnols
et un accord de dernière minute avant la
fin de l'année entre bruxelles et le
royaume uni sont encore possibles disons
que ça n'est pas exclue parce que la
grande bretagne perdra beaucoup dans un
odile dans une absence d'accord
dans la mesure où 50% des exportations
de tout le royaume uni vont vers les 27
états membres de l'union européenne et
que s'il n'y a pas d'accord
et bien il y aura des droits de douane
du tarif douanier commun d'union
européenne sur ses importations en
provenance du royaume uni bien sûr dans
l'autre sens il en sera de même et
niveau moyen de ces tarifs douaniers et
d'environ 4 à 5% mais cela renchérira
les prix des marchandises échangées des
deux côtés la grande bretagne a beaucoup
plus à perdre que l'union européenne
puisque l'union européenne n'exporte que
8 % de ses exportations vers l'or
jomini elle a cependant à perdre et
notamment pour ceux qui exportent des
véhicules automobiles comme notamment
l'allemagne puisque le droit de douane
sera à ce moment là de 10 % au
royaume-uni
donc il ya un intérêt finalement des de
toutes les parties à conclure
bien sûr ce encore une fois perdre la
face sans transiger sur les principes
pour l'union européenne
la sauvegarde du marché unique bien
entendu il faut pas que ce soit à marché
unique avec des trous partout pour il
faut aussi naturellement respecter les
droits historiques de pêche qui que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure
et puis pour le royaume uni de grande
bretagne et bien ne pas transiger sur le
fait que la grande bretagne veut
retrouver sa pleine souveraineté
ce n'est probablement pas impossible sur
le plan technique de trouver les
solutions
et puis pour terminer après tout est-ce
bien le bon moment en pleine deuxième
vague du coc vite 19 d'aller établir des
postes frontières avec des douaniers qui
vont créer un désordre considérable aux
frontières à partir du 1er janvier
prochain et qui seront probablement
d'ailleurs impossible à faire
fonctionner dans le climat actuel de
pandémie
donc après tout la clause la delà de la
la de la force majeure pourrait être
invoquée si les britanniques le
souhaitez et si l'union européenne
accepte est pour dire eh bien reportons
les délais de six mois ou d'un an
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales